uh professor sorry do you mind checking  your gmail real quick i just sent you my  unpublished novel i  was wondering if you might be able to  give me some notes or something let's  see  um it's technically catalin fanfic  i i don't know if that's uh these two  things don't look like they go together  oh well they obviously do thank you  i told you he would like it it's a very  kind of  disney romance right not exactly  do i have a chance at getting something  like this published be honest  generally in my experience not worked  but your mileage may vary there may be  publishers who think it worked  fantastically well  that's good that's good they may come in  and say we need another sex scene right  here did not expect that to be a problem  actually can i ask you another question  hint  something's wrong here you're right i am  taking up everyone's time  sorry dad you are breaking some weird  [Music]  rules  [Music]  you